it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we reveal the stories behind the
headlines and for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond it looks like the Biden
campaign finally found a job for Kamala
well you might call her
embajadora Harris the Ambassador once
again they dispatched her to Chicago her
second visit in two weeks to speak to a
democratic Latino group Harris saying
the OneNote sambalora and that note was
extremists extremists
so-called leaders
have a blueprint to attack hard one
freedoms
extremists so-called leaders
demonize Target and attack immigrants
extremists also attack the freedom to
vote can you imagine
book bands in this year of Our Lord 2023
and for these extremists that was not
enough we all have so much more in
common
than what separates us
in common with the extremists I guess
Harris is trying to shore up the Latino
support Laura which is slipping badly
axios reports that Latinos still favor
Democrats but their allegiance is
drifting due to you guessed it cultural
issues crime and the economy Biden has
lost four points with Latinos since
October but I don't think Kamala and her
extremist talk is going to exactly Build
It Up is it just me or was it just
echoing in there was there a lot of
Applause it didn't seem like there was
much of a not much of a reaction there
she was greeted like a Country Music
Television executive at a Jason Aldean
concert nobody responded anyway as you
know Laura and I'm looking at your
outfit Bob Barbie won the box office
this weekend with a 162 million dollar
Hall lots of people attended the movie
in pink get-ups uh politicians tried to
get in on the ACT we talked about
Gretchen Whitmer and then there were
these string of AI fakes featuring Obama
and Biden but this is an actual
California state Senator Scott weiner
getting his Barbie on
[Music]
these people have to stop Laura weiner
incidentally is the senator who honored
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence at
the California state house he's also the
guy who made it illegal to not recognize
the gender uh identity of your child
criminalizing that for parents this
summer I don't know if that's quite in
Barbie's World it's creepy his whole I
don't even know what he was doing there
he just
sometimes it just the adults should stay
away from that type of social media
although I have to admit two of my
children did go to Barbie over the
weekend well and I see you and I see
you're repping the Barbie colors tonight
too I wasn't going to mention it but
there you are finally Laura during some
bombshell hearings on Capitol Hill we
noticed a few things that I'm sure
neither Republicans nor Democrats
intended first of all when you have an
important IRS whistleblower or two
testifying don't let the tick tock boys
mug behind them do you see these two
kids they mug throughout the whole
hearing okay after several minutes
somebody finally motioned to them and
said hey boys come here they removed the
duo but the wackiest moment of all was
that the big censorship hearing with RFK
Jr congresswoman democratic
congresswoman Stacy Plaskett offered
this speech clearly written by the
staffer behind her who dramatically
interpreted every phrase watch her she
does age 50 55 from the committee's
interview with FBI employee Roya demelo
who you just spoke about which took
place on July 17 2023 they would be
representing what I said because I don't
have much knowledge of that
they would be misrepresenting
what I said because I don't have much
knowledge of that
okay Laura first rule of film never let
the extras upstage you and no commentary
in the background always a bad look her
eyes are interesting they they look I
don't want to say crazy I don't want to
say anything mean here but they look a
little crazy like a little crazy eyes
behind her like a little something a
little unhinged about those eyes but she
wrote it so she wants it to be delivered
correctly yeah but she memorized the
whole speech she's mouthing the words
that's an accomplishment but yeah that's
a little high octane even for a
congressional staff less coffee I would
recommend no but this is this is what
you notice okay you notice these things
like I'm actually listening for the
substance you're looking for Crazy Eyes
behind her okay I'm watching weird Boys
lyrics Kid all right great man great to
see you all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else